let's check out zach please he's a
northeast ohio ford dealers indian
starting pitcher this afternoon zach is
making his 10th start this year uh
coming off a start against the angels he
got the win he went seven innings he
gave up
seven hits and three of them were home
runs but he hung in there pitched well
enough in his last five starts he's 3-0
with a 248 era get command to the strike
zone keep the ball down he's made one
start against minnesota this year was a
no decision he went seventh two thirds
innings gave up three runs right fielder
max kepler he's been phd with a sore
hamstring but today and right indians
shift to the right and kepler drives one
toward the gap in left center and on the
run reaching out and making a basket
catch is left fielder eddie rosario
well that was a heck of a running grab
and a basket catch on the run by eddie
rosario
as we mentioned two tough starts against
the chicago white sox other than that
he's he's been spectacular he's gonna
have to use this fourth scene
get happy with the four scene fastball
stay away from the heart of the plate
and the indians get a lead off single
it'll bring up jose ramirez switch
hitter batting right-handed swung on and
hammered high deep to left near the wall
learn again he leaps in it's above his
head hits off the wall cams back toward
the infield hernandez is heading for
home ramirez on the throw to the plate
will scamper to third and the indians
have a one-nothing lead
larnick
thought he could scale that 19-foot wall
and the ball still landed above his
outstretched glove about halfway up the
19-foot wall and then a hard ricochet
back toward the infield
and that enabled hernandez to score from
first
and ramirez when he saw the throw
go to the plate
kept moving to third and the indians
have taken a one-nothing lead so the
indians leaned one-nothing and now
trying to make it a multiple run inning
swinging a chopper through the left side
this will be a base hit into left center
in the scores ramirez and the shift
backfires on the twins
it's the routine chopper to where the
shortstop normally would be
but in the shift that ball just kept
traveling through the infield indians at
first and second for ahmed rosario two
down in the second two to nothing
there's a ground ball single in the
right field what a job by rosario took
the fastball the other way coming home
to score is chang on his way to third
hernandez and the indians get the two
out knock from rosario to make it three
to nothing and boy the indians
situational hitting today has been
terrific
three nothing tries three nothing
cleveland bottom three it'll be four
five and six swinging a fly ball softly
left center field now moving to his
right is rough snyder he'll dive and
catch
for out number one nothing soft about
that that pulled me off the bat
that was it to deep left center field
rep snyder lost his sunglasses dove to
his right superman diving and catching
good play
and luplow now a hard luck oh for 14.
one out
first and second nobody out here comes
max kepler
twins on the move trailing three nothing
here in the fourth and kepler left one
high and deep to right field deep to the
corner and gone a game time three run
home run
and after going nine up nine down to
start the game the first three twins hit
and score here in the fourth on to the
concourse
for kepler 3-3 fourth inning
it's now 17 home runs lifetime kepler
against cleveland the bases are now
loaded with only one out this went from
wait it might be zach police day two he
might not get out of the inning in a
hurry
the eighth man to bat in the inning is
rob ref snyder swung on and up towards
third and past the third baseman ramirez
into left field for a ground ball base
here kiriloff scores and it's 4-3
minnesota just a slow roller through the
left side of the diamond and it gets the
job done and the twins lead 4-3 their
first lead of the ball game
chopped to the right side
fumbled by the first baseman and police
act did he get a foot on the bag
yes but another run comes in that's it
for the tribe starting pitcher zach
pleisak is inconsolable in that dugout
he could literally probably bite through
a steel cable right here yeah he's gonna
give him a three-nothing lead and he
breezed through the first three innings
and then all of a sudden you can't get
out of the fourth so here's ahmed
rosario rbi single first time up he's
one for two and he's been a hot hitter
of late he swings and lines it to right
center field that's headed to the alley
and it splits the gap up against the
wall hernandez will score easily
rosario's flying toward third the throw
safe
in rbi triple for rosario
and it's a one-run ball game
twins five try four
man did rosario
really open it up coming around second
base
and he made it to third just ahead of
the throw
as he looked like he was thinking triple
right out of the box drive down the run
tying running first two down sixth honey
swag on a miss he struck him out it was
a fast ball up ten strikeouts for j hat
luplow hence to first rosario at second
two down in the seventh twins with a
five to four lead and oh with former
twin eddie rosario
love to flip the script here ground ball
right side it's going by rise from right
field throws the first close play and
they got him caleb field covering first
base kirilov
backing up loved it from right field
eddie rosario diving head first trying
to beat it could not an opportunity now
for the indians to tie the score late in
the ball game and it's swung on grounded
sharply to short backhanded by simmons
goes to third they've got ramirez and a
rundown and cenote tags them out so a
base running blunder by ramirez he took
off for third base and the four-time
gold glove winner simmons at short saw
that
the backhanded that ball deep in the
hole lifted up his head and the play on
ramirez was there and ceno with a
perfectly executed run down ran him back
no throw ran him back let the runner
make the move and cenote tagged him out
for the second out what a great start to
this inning and jose now is the man of
the hour captain clutch has done it all
season long to this point high fly ball
deep center ref snider
makes the catch
tying run will tag and go to third
hernandez the tying run at third jordan
luke lowe the batter hole for three with
a walk he bugs it here comes the tying
run scoop safe
luplow with a
safety squeeze bunt hernandez slid in
ahead of the tag what a bunt on the
first base side by jordan luplow so
minnesota has a really good start to the
10th they've got two on and new buddy
out
and kyle garlick coming up and the
payoff pitch is swinging a fly ball
right center field deep back it goes
deep it goes and go on a home run kyle
garlick takes karen jack deep to right
center field
finally a big at bat in the 10th inning
and the twins surge in front eight to
five and silence progressive field
runner at third base jake bowers at
first tying run at the plate and the
twins win in extra innings win the
series and will head home with a winning
road trip